hello I'm here with
Giacomo Harvey in San Diego at Sony's
motion capture studio and I wanted to
put together a little behind the scenes
thing for Killing Floor 2 we've just
gotten done with a five-day shoot on the
exciting Killing Floor 2 project and we
definitely crushed in pretty bad and
this is our second one so in total we've
done eight days and we're gonna have one
more probably the beginning of next year
and it's a little little snippet you
guys can see to get you excited for the
game next year and see what we were up
to
so so I mean as you know you know in
Killing Floor 2 we want to take all the
creatures to the next level and we you
know we have 12 very diverse creatures
like which one did you you know or ones
did you find the most interesting or
engaging co-op liner that's difficult
question they're all fascinating
individuals I think the plot was the
most interesting and engaging because
it's three different versions of the
same sort of clone character similar
sort of I guess features but very
different language
you got one who's like the Alpha you
know and you got another one it's like a
crazed crackhead psychopath and then
another one that's like a child will rip
your arms off yes I basically took my
childhood my teenage years and my adult
years and so smashed them together and
found those three distinct individuals
from my own yeah rapid crazy blood
lusting experience yeah the crawler the
crawler was great frontier I think most
of my inspiration for the features like
crawler and socialist came from the
animal kingdom the peacock spider was a
big inspiration a Corolla yeah and I
have to say don't get don't get me wrong
I'm quite comfortable with my
masculinity but I did kind of enjoy
playing ladies a little bit siren yeah
he did play the stalker siren understood
all the features but don't tell anyone
yeah yeah or else yeah the the stalker
turn out really cool I really like the
the moods you did you know one really
interesting thing that we did is you
know we kind of planned out what we
wanted and we had a vibe from the first
game but we really tried to develop the
creatures to take them farther and
jáchym oh we just let him run with it
and he just looked took everything to
the next level and we did very you know
very freeform experimenting see what
worked really well and I think I think
the fancy guys are really really going
to dig what we've done with the the
creatures it has a really unique feel
and style to it
so which which character did you find
the most challenging to play I think
that the bloat was probably the most
challenging because it had some real
some sort of real constraints on the
character legitimate constraints like
the weight is a huge character and and
there are certain limitations
I would imagine when you're carrying
around that much weight which had to be
very careful of whereas the other
crawler and the you know the siren and
and so forth that there's sort of
unprecedent that the bloat is it kind of
a realistic precedent that we'd have to
and then hone in on it's hard to be
dangerous and cumbersome at the same
thing right especially when you got used
to playing agile freaks like the plot
yeah I think it probably took us 20
minutes to show you yeah yeah with a bit
of bill and Bert waddling around the
ball over better upon the natural
blurred often than Jackman which I
cannot applaud them enough for doing
because it just inspires and motivates
me um you know yeah maybe someday we'll
we'll put out some of the videos that
birth myself and injustice has done I
think the folks at home again take out
yeah yeah I don't think I will
I wouldn't beat out the door just were a
lot of this creature work if not for the
reference videos that the villain Bert
you sent me ahead of time thank you very
much for taking the time to do it I just
want to say it's been it's been an honor
working with you men we're so lucky to
it had you working on this project I
can't thank you enough I think you guys
are gonna see just how awesome awesome
everything feels with the the creatures
and a big part of that is the span here
Jack about Harvey I don't know about you
but I can't wait to play the game yeah
me all right all right we'll stay tuned
and I'll see you next year
under my scientific leadership horizion
is achieved unparalleled success and is
trusted the world over we are driving
the Renaissance of science we
you